okay so with spider-man no way home not
only breaking the multiverse internet
and the minds of every single marvel
maniac out there i thought i'd take a
look back at the movie that started it
all to talk about the best details in it
though it was made way before easter egg
hunters like myself obsessed over every
single shot in frame the movie is filled
to the brim with things most people miss
and we're still uncovering things about
it 20 years later the movie follows
spider-man as he goes toe-to-toe with
the green goblin and it's definitely a
battle for the ages several scenes
including the goblin's death are ripped
right out of the pages of the amazing
spider-man 1-2-2 in which he was impaled
by his own glider both norman osborne
and peter share somewhat of a father and
son relationship in the wake of uncle
ben's death but beyond this it's clear
norman wishes his son was more like
peter the idea of them being mirror
images of one another is shown during
the thanksgiving dinner in which the
pair wear the opposite's colours peter
wears a green shirt with a purple tie
whereas norman wears a blue shirt with a
red one going beyond this though harry
wears a mixture of both which somewhat
hints towards his fractured allegiances
throughout the entire trilogy there's
also several callbacks to this movie
with harry later down the line and when
peter first meets him he's wearing a
burgundy sweater with a t-shirt
underneath and a hoodie jacket over the
top in spider-man 3 when harry has
amnesia he also wears a similar set of
colours showing how his mind state has
gone back several years to the events of
this movie now willem dafoe really
embodies the role and it's easy to see
why they brought him back for no way
home the actor exudes a lot from his
facial expressions and during the scene
in which he acted against demira he did
these entirely in one take jumping back
and forth between the personas however
the creative team actually did something
really subtle to make it so that there
was an extra creepy factor to him and
when willem is playing the norman
osborne side he wears fake teeth that
makes his smile seem more in line
however when he's leaning into being the
goblin these are removed and we get
those awesome canine fang-like ones
creeping through his grin during the
green goblin jump scare that happens in
the film if you slow down the footage
you can also catch a second green goblin
standing in the background it's super
unnerving when you watch it and though
most people won't notice it it
subliminally gives the idea that the
goblin is supernatural however it also
might be hinting towards how a second
goblin will come down the line not too
far behind him in the form of harry when
he attacks j jonah jameson's office you
can also see that they've subtly painted
big black irises onto his mask which
gives them a bug-eyed look that's in
line with his costume from the comics
his home is also filled with the brain
with masks from ancient tribes and this
of course hints towards the goblin and
his subconscious now norman is very much
a tormented character and though we
never fully learn what happened to his
wife it's clear it was pretty bad just
before the balcony attack harry tells mj
that she should have worn black because
his father loves that colour and when
we're in the house we can catch a brief
glimpse out of mrs osborne who's wearing
a black dress at the dinner we then see
mj wearing black showing that she was
trying to impress norman even though it
didn't go down very well now norman says
that all women are beautiful until
they're snarling after your trust fund
like a pack of ravening wolves and thus
i think the woman in the portrait is
probably norman's mother this
thanksgiving dinner scene also has a lot
of similarities to the painting by
norman rockwell called freedom from want
i absolutely love how this shot is used
in a similar manner to demonstrate all
the characters coming together for one
final time before everyone ends up in
the crosshairs of the goblin now i feel
like we've been talking about the goblin
a lot and the true main character of
spider-man is of course well spider-man
see i told you it was amazing details on
this video now earlier in the movie
peter is bitten by a genetically altered
spider and we actually get some
foreshadowing of his powers on a screen
giving a cgi rendition of the arachnids
dna these include things like web
tensile strength spider strength jumping
speed spider sense precognition which
i'm guessing is the same as spider sense
and speed again the dna strands are
flying or red blue and green colours
that are of course associated with
spider-man and the green goblin we also
see a spider using its strength to
dangle a much heavier object by a web
string which somewhat foreshadows
spider-man holding onto the dangling
cable car later on in the movie now
peter also ends up taking a photograph
of mj and shouts new rock stars for
pointing out that this picture shows up
later in spider-man 2 in peter's
apartment peter ends up getting organic
webbing in the movie but at one point in
the film we can catch the web shooters
on his wrist which were originally
supposed to be a part of the plot but
these were later removed personally i
actually prefer the organic webbing as
what's the point of getting bit by a
spider if you can't shoot webs out your
ass now at one point in the film peter
eats lunch at school and if you look
closely at his hand you'll see a red
line coming down from the spider bite
indicating the track of its venom
speaking of venom robbie later brings up
to jameson their photographer eddie and
he says that he can't get a decent
photograph of spider-man this is of
course a reference to eddie brock and in
spider-man 3 he reuses peter's old
pictures touching them up with photoshop
in order to get paid now during this
lunch scene we watches peter catches
mary jane and also her lunch this moment
was actually done for real without any
cgi and though it apparently took 156
takes toby maguire actually managed to
do it the trick was pulled off using
adhesive which you can see on the bottom
of the apple and also magnets water fire
air and dirt [ __ ] magnets how do they
work well i'll explain and if you slow
down the footage you'll see that the
jelly actually bounces back on top of
the milk carton because of the magnet
that's laced on the inside of it now if
you look closely at peter's hand when he
shoots the webbing at the lunch tray
you'll also see that he makes the
spider-man web-firing gesture he doesn't
figure out until later on that this is
how you fire webs but i love that they
have this happening here to show exactly
why it went off now during this time
peter discovers his powers and he ends
up going to a rooftop where he tries to
fire his webs he says up up and away web
and also shazam the both of which are
references to superman and shazam
superman is also brought up by ant-may
later and i love the theory that in the
marvel universe our dc characters are
who are in the comic books and in the dc
universe marvels are the one on the page
this would explain why the flash has so
many marvel references in it and it's a
really nice fan theory now there's also
a moment where jameson looks through
peter's photos and he calls them all
crap i kind of think this might be a
reference to batman 1999 when the joker
does the same thing with vicki vales and
i promise that's the one reach for the
video what would you be they're all
riches now those dc ones are pretty
obvious easter eggs but this scene is
given a nod in spider-man homecoming
when ned asks peter how far he can shoot
his web and he says that if it was him
he'd just stand on the edge of a
building and shoot it to see how far it
goes now if you're enjoying the video
i'd massively appreciate the thumbs up
and i've got you for three more minutes
three minutes of bleed time but if you
want to stay around longer then please
subscribe who am i you sure you want to
know well i'm somewhat of an idiot
myself but the name's paul and this is
the heavy spoilers show now uncle ben's
death is a massive part of the
spider-man origin story and the
performance from cliff robertson was so
iconic that lines from his performance
were actually used years later in into
the spider-verse the conversation that
happens between peter and ben is really
impactful and it takes place in an
oldsmobile delta 88. the core has
appeared in a number of sam remy films
including the evil dead evil dead 2 dark
man army of darkness and also in drag me
to hell when peter exits if you slow
down the footage you can catch his red
hoodie hanging out the back of his
clothes too and he later go on to wear
this as part of his wrestling costume
the robber who apparently kills uncle
ben though i don't really count sandman
is doing it actually also appears in the
amazing spider-man once more showing
that yes it's all connected now during
this time we also see the origin story
of the green goblin and alongside him is
dr mendel strom who fans of the comics
might know as being a half man half
machine villain at one point in the
movie peter actually catches mary jane
working at the moon dan steiner and if
you've seen tiktik boom you'll know that
this location pops up in a 2 as being
where jonathan larson works at larson is
played by andrew garfield who of course
played spider-man and i love how this
all kind of ties together for trivia
fans also there's a cameo by lucy lulas
at one point who you may know is playing
xena the warrior princess now this movie
isn't perfect and there's faults in it
too like when peter is testing his
webbing as he shoots one at a lamp and
ends up smashing it and made a knocks
and when we cut back to a bigger shot of
the room we can see that the lampshade
is back where it was completely fixed
we'll forgive it though as he also
smashes a photo of himself ben and may
and later this shows up by ant-may's
bedside in a brand new photo frame
little touches like this and just
everything in the video that make this
movie great and i still have as much fun
with it now as it did all the way back
in 2002 i absolutely love it and if
there's any easter eggs in i miss then
make sure you comment below and let me
know we are in competition right now and
giving away three copies of the
spider-man 4k trilogies on the 30th of
december and all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the video we
picked the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one are on screen right now so that's
you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of the spiderman across if
you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the spider-man across the spider-verse
first look which will be linked on
screen right now some really cool easter
eggs in it and lots of hidden details
that hint towards the movie's plot so
definitely go check it out right after
this if not then thanks for sitting
through the video i've been paul you've
been the best and i'll see you on the
next one take care peace